how do you feel about hollywood after
making this documentary
um
hollywood is this place where stories
are told right and we all love to hear
stories we've been doing it since we
were cavemen sitting around you know the
campfire and
you know exchanging stories and you know
they're they're designed to
to learn from raise our consciousness
you know
um
to learn from
and um
hollywood's a place where they tell
those stories on whatever scale or other
you know
um
and
i
personally find that if i'm involved in
any of those stories as an actor which i
find myself being
um
you know that's wonderful opportunity
and a chance to play and you know enjoy
and and hopefully serve that script
serve that character as best i can
but for me i find that you know journeys
like uh this american journey with the
documentary
you know that's when i really sort of
see humanity you know i mean whether
it's american humanity or if i go to
india and i see indian people living in
a certain way or africa or china or any
of these places and i personally like to
get out there where you know
everyday sort of folks are living in
everyday ways
and
also finding a lot more happiness than
one might sort of think exists in you
know poor places
i remember going to mali once which is
the third poorest place in the world and
i've never seen some smiley happy faces
you can walk around beverly hills and
then you can wait all day for somebody
to smile you know and
there's a there's a difference going on
there um
without criticizing any situation or
other but you know one can't help but
notice these things and i just find that
the more i travel around um and the more
people that i'm exposed to the more
humanity i'm exposed to so if i'm going
to be popped into you know placed into
one of these hollywood stories or tv
shows or films or whatever then if i've
experienced a bit more humanity from
some far-flung places then maybe i'm a
little bit more uh better equipped to to
portray that character in some way or
other you know
um
i would hope so and so for me it's um
it's important you know not just to sort
of stay in little bubbles you know in
hollywood or you know manhattan or or
london or whatever it's important for me
personally to sort of get out there and
see what's going on in the world
and then when all these stories in
hollywood are told you're like oh yeah i
saw something like that once so yeah i
can bring that into it now and
hopefully do a slightly better job
you